à salut à tous bon sang ça aujourd'hui
pour soir une faq
il ya plein de questions qui m'ont été
posées suis ta dernière faq ça c'est
vraiment très très cool on va donc
aujourd'hui parce que ça va s que le
cadre est bien je m'installe un
tranquille on fait ça en même temps
voyez comme ça on partage tous les
instants on se dit tous ces tops petit
ordinateur ici avec toutes les questions
posées je vous invite à prendre un verre
regardez moi j'ai pris un petit verre je
me suis servi un petit verre en trinquet
santé le tango salsa allez vous chercher
un verre prenez à boire mettez vous à
l'aise
il ya plein de questions qui m'ont été
posées je suis vraiment très très
content je vous remercie parce que vous
êtes de plus en plus nombreuses et de
plus en plus nombreux à me poser toutes
vos questions ou de faq c'est vachement
cool
[Musique]
alors on y va pourquoi acheter des
smartphones chinois car on doit les
importer alors qu'on se plaint de la
surconsommation et du réchauffement
climatique timothée je suis entièrement
d'accord avec toi c'est vrai que c'est
souvent des paradoxes
on se plaint de pas mal de choses mais
malgré tout on le fait aussi par contre
qu'il faut savoir c'est que tous les
smartphones sont fabriquées fin de
quasiment tous en tout cas il n'y a pas
qu'en chine mais beaucoup les
smartphones sont fabriqués en chine le
savoir faire est là bas les usines sont
là bas et donc forcément les smartphones
viennent de chine même si les marques ne
sont pas chinoises s'allume ce gros tube
conseil au moins de plus cet été promet
30 pro note 10 plus ou l'iphone
on se promet axe là tu mets que les
téléphones qui sont dans le haut du
panier ça va dépendre de thésut usage tu
me parles d'une autre 10 plus ça c'est
la question du style et c'est à partir
du stylet vasto sur un ace 10 plus qui
coûtera un peu moins cher etc sera très
très très bon one plus cette épreuve la
question ça va être trop surtout le
grand écran 90 hier c'est ce que tu as
veut cette fluidité ce que tu es gamers
peut aussi avoir un sens mais il trompe
cros les bat tc lons que je peux pas
t'en parler aujourd'hui l'iphone
on se promet aussi très très bon c'est
aussi le choix de l'ouest si tu vas sur
l'iphone c'est l'eau est ce que tu veux
c'est à ios c'est là toi de répondre
mais c'est soit on les trouve tous très
bien se dit le maître en prose les
pattes et celle plus compliqué mais tous
les autres j'aime beaucoup où en plus
cet éperon est moins cher si vous être
un critère de choix est ce que je prends
des risques si je commande montreynaud
de suite sur gears baisse ou à l'express
j'ai envie de dire non je veux dire si
tu peux payer payer avec paypal c'est
toujours mieux parce que paypal afin de
la médiation ce que de foyers un
problème il avouerait question qui se
pose derrière c'est la question du sav
pas tant d'avoir les produits parce que
je suis pas à qui sont le fait de télé
produit chez dire baisse tout l express
mais c'est vraiment la question si
toutefois il ya un problème après
comment tu fais pour pouvoir récupérer
ton produit tout la garantie c'est
toujours un petit peu ça le problème
derrière arrête de nous faire visiter
des chambres d'hôtel on s'en fiche
nicolas moi j'aime bien faire ça à
partager ça partager mon soutient
d'ailleurs dit moi si ça vous intéresse
vous qui regardez
est ce que vous aimez quand je vous
emmène en voyage avec moi une fois celle
ci peut découvrir les coulisses les
chambres d'hôtel tous a marqué les mois
en bas en commentaire
et d'ailleurs toutes vos questions pour
la prochaine facture vous pouvez les
poser dès maintenant à les y aidera
faites vous plaisir
si vous avez des questions sur les
smartphones vous pouvez y aller piano
beaucoup ses moyens qu'on puisse varier
un petit peu si vous avez des questions
sur la chaîne sur l'univers la chaîne
sur tout ça tout ça tout ça sur youtube
en général
vous pouvez y aller je me fais un très
grand plaisir pouvoir vous répondre
d'ailleurs un an d'affaires à la bonne
vôtre fait les visites pour assister aux
présentations des grandes marques ont
souvent sur invitation ou quiconque peut
y aller c'est uniquement sur invitation
il ya certaines marques qui ouvre des
places pour leurs fans xiaoming wang
plus entre autres pour ne citer qu'eux
mais non c'est tout sur invitation sont
des événements réservés à la presse tu
préfères airbus ou boeing airbus
bonjour c'est encore moi gisèle depuis
le cameroun salut 6l depuis le cameroun
et bonjour à tous les amis qui sont en
afrique côte d'ivoire ghana repartent ou
bisous à tous mon frère et moi adorons
et vidéos trop cool merci beaucoup mais
dis-moi lequel préfères-tu entre le mit
9t le samsung à 50 et le au port et nos
aux ports et docks pour la photo et bien
marche plutôt bien même s'il y aurait
une ou deux qui est sorti qui est quand
même au dessus et qui écoute comme ça
brûle pour poissons trop réfléchir je te
dirai 1900c quoi ta marque préférée de
smartphones et d'électronique parce
qu'on dirait que tout le monde adore
apple
juste parce que ça coûte cher lucas les
personnes qui vont aimer apple c'est pas
parce que ça coûte cher
il n'y a pas de côté ostentatoire dont
côté se dire j'ai un apple ça coûte cher
j'ai d'argent je me la pète je pense pas
qu'on soit là dedans les gens qui aiment
apple aime pour l'écosystème m pour la
marque m paul wes c'est ça qui est
intéressant que la marque c'est que
l'écosystème marche parfaitement bien
c'est très facile à utiliser ce à côté
de ça les produits qu'ils fabriquent
sont de bonne facture marche bien sont
cool mais ils sont chers moi j'aime
beaucoup apple
j'aime pas uniquement apple il ya
beaucoup d'autres marques que j'aime
beaucoup
donc c'est vrai que c'est compliqué de
faire un choix entre ios et android
kaeppelin produit il praful côté de chez
android donc voilà apple c'est bien mais
y'a pas que pour ce qu'il fait un jour
une ou des vidéos sur une nouvelle
console de jeux je les ai déjà fait bien
longtemps sur la xbox one-x peut-être à
voir pourquoi pas sur une nouvelle
playstation plus tard pour pas comment
te considères-tu dick ou techno ou les
2,6 et les deux tu peux faire une belle
vidéo sur la tesla model x alors je me
considère ni dit ni techno je me
considère curieux des nouvelles
technologies c'est plutôt simple idée
oui j'adorerais faire une vidéo sur la
tesla model x on parlera peut-être de
tesla plus tard peut-être dirt et cela
si vous regardez cette vidéo je veux
bien faire une vidéo sur une voiture
vous pouvez me contacter afin d'ouvrir
un vieux type non je suis pas trop fan
du système de
your type ça te dirait une raclette made
in sa voix je t'invite à la maison merci
beaucoup pour l'invitation j'adore la
raclée de médine savoir lequel vaut plus
le coup à 50 iphone 7 avec les galaxy
bozoulais repose alors c'est compliqué
si on regarde que les écouteurs les
galaxies bosch des ânes bien mais je
préfère les reproches pour que la
qualité audio est meilleur il ya un très
très beau travail qui est fait est clair
tout s'est toujours très bien maîtrisé
après à 50 ou iphone 7 l'a51 un peu plus
récents l'iphone 4 est pas mal je dirais
peut-être à 50 avec les reposer je
compte m'acheter l'iphone 10r chez sfr
car c'est là qu'il est le moins cher est
ce que l'iphone 10 r eh bien oui
l'iphone 10r et bien la résolution de
l'écran est pas folle par contre la
dalle est vachement bien la colorimétrie
tout est juste c'est vraiment très bien
là puisque adam est toujours très actuel
ça marche parfaitement bien que penses
tu de blackberry
ils font très bon produit intéressant
très riche et s'adresse pas tout le
monde mais qui offre une valeur
intéressante pour tous ceux qui sont
intéressés par cette typologie de
produits
j'ai un iphone 10 et je n'ai pas craqué
pour le onze pros mais j'aurais voulu
savoir si tu penses que toutes les
annonces promises cette année reduction
treaty sbc cetera seront présentes sans
les fon 11 aces de l'année prochaine ou
alors le 12 dans deux ans c'est très
compliqué de pouvoir se projeter savoir
ce qu'on nous propose et apple en termes
de produits en termes de valeur je ne
doute pas qu'ils cherchent toujours à
aller plus haut
ils vont garder faille saïdi peut-être
intégrer un peu différemment j'aimerais
en tout cas moi qu'ils l'attaquent
différemment qu'ils puissent intégrer
fejsa il dit sous l'écran ça serait
vraiment bien ça me semblait en tout cas
aller dans le bon sens pour enfants de
ces petites encoches qui est so 2017
l'usb c'est pourquoi pas ça serait bien
qu'ils mettent une connectique usb c'est
pour que tous soient uniformisées de ce
point de vue là ça pourrait en tout cas
avoir un sens coucou aurais tu un petit
drone qui rentre dans un sac à dos
normal compatible avec un smartphone
samsung qui montrent assez haut alain
tarifs 4 350 euros à me conseiller s'il
te plaît arnaud je suis pas un
spécialiste à des drones je te
conseillerais d'aller faire un petit
tour du côté de shit dj ait qui en bon
produit il y en a un peu pour tous les
tarifs 350 euros faut voir si tu peux
trouver un truc bien du côté du spark
qui pour le coup est pas trop grand je
sais pas quel prix les mais en tout cas
il ya but ou intéressant
j'ai beaucoup dernier de wang plus mais
ce genre de marque n'est pas distribué
pourquoi y at il moyen d avoir car
acheter ou en plus cette pro s'était
m'ennuie un peu de l'acheter nu pour le
prix c'est la stratégie de distribution
sur lesquels les canaux de distribution
des marques
il ya certaines marques qui ne sont pas
avec les opérateurs parce qu'ils n'ont
pas de deal avec les opérateurs y en a
d'autres qui en ont je sais pas si loin
de plus depuis leur dernier modèle
un deal pour j'ai un doute je suis pas
sûr mais j'ai un doute là dessus
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'elle est
effectivement ça peut être compliqué la
saison smartphone sans opérateur parce
que ça a un certain coût tu comptes
faire le test de la marque u midi j j'ai
déjà testé
gisèle dès midi j ya quelques temps je
sais pas si j'en referai je vois souvent
passer leur communiqué de presse avec
leur nouveau smartphone
je sais pas dit pas dire ça vous
intéresse que je parlais ce matin du
midi j par quel émoi en bas en
commentaire one + 7 pro ou 7 t et deux
smartphones sont bienveillants d'écran
90 hertz
il ya la petite encoche au niveau du
cepd et qui me paraît être un peu moins
intéressante
par contre que c'était beaucoup plus
intéressant ça le flagship killer qui
est extrêmement bien positionnée en
termes de taille et donc c'est une
question tarif le cepd et si vous voulez
le grand écran sans encoches le centro
j'en ai parlé dans ma dernière vidéo du
mclaren où je fais un peu un comparatif
des ces modèles là les jeter un petit
coup d'oeil comme ça vous sauver tous
j'aimerais savoir ce que tu fais de tous
les parcs que tu testes la plupart des
smartphones repart directement chez les
marchés en garde quelques uns qui me
servent pour mon labo pour faire des
tests ultérieurs avec les nouveaux
modèles pour pouvoir les comparer tu
préfères les fautes 17 ou le samsung
s10e très intéressant pierre je crois
comme ça à brûle pourpoint je dirais le
galaxy s 10e
j'ai beaucoup aimé ce smartphone
j'aimerais acheter au moins de +7 tepa
le prouve son appareil puissant car j'ai
pas confiance en actions 256 gigaoctets
mille ne sera pas vendu en france
la seule possibilité de s'en procurer
ans et de l'acheter sur le site one +
indien as tu déjà acheté des produits
high tech sur les sites indien s'est tu
parles du site officiel de wang plus en
inde tu achète directement chez one plus
maintenant le problème que tu vas
rencontrer sait déjà est ce que le site
indien livre en europe je suis pas sûr
si tu en europe donc à voir vous tuer
est-ce qu'il y en a en tout cas là où tu
es j'en suis pas sûr est le deuxième
poste avec la problématique de la
garantie puisque tu as garantie dépendra
du site indien concéda qu'il faut que tu
renvoies qu'on produit là-bas c'est
toujours un peu la question du rsa mais
qui complique quand on va sur des
produits étrangers comme ça en tout cas
que que je mesurerai le truc c'est une
entreprise paysagiste en coopérative
donc j'utilise un logiciel de
comptabilité pour coopérative avec
internet sachant que j'ai acheté un
ordinateur de bureau imaginer ok ok ok
quel ordinateur portable serait le mieux
en complément pour un prix raisonnable
ou une tablette
alors pierre toi tu es paysagiste donc
ça veut dire que probablement
potentiellement tu es souvent en
extérieur je te conseillerai donc une
tablette peut-être que tu vas faire des
croquis je sais pas une petite tablette
avec un petit stylet temps de la prise
de notes rapides pour faire des croquis
je pense que ça doit avoir un sens avec
ton métier je me dirigerai peut-être
là-dessus va acheter un coup d'oeil sur
la dernière tablette de samsung la s6 ça
peut être intéressant avec le petit
clavier en plus pour coter productivité
ça peut être plutôt pas mal
salut de ce cru en ce moment j'ai un
samsung galaxy jitrois qu'ai je vais
bientôt changer j'hésite entre le a70
salut à 80 lequel choisir je te
conseille d'attendre quelques jours je
vais parler du à 80 sa part me rappelle
de faire une meilleure idée là-dessus
s'allument sur eux comme conseils tu
entre le one + 7 t pro et le note 10
puces alors floflo moi je pense que la
question va se poser une fois de plus en
10 plus par rapport à l'usagé du stylet
est ce que tu as besoin de l'usaj du
spns qui te le faut si on a pas besoin
pose toi la question plutôt d'un galaxy
s 10 plus qui aura peut-être un peu plus
de sens
le one piece est très pro et cool
notamment ce grand écran sans encoches
écran 90 ème logo de plus un peu plus
performant que le modèle de samsung mais
ça joue dans un mouchoir de poche à
savoir si tu fais du gué mis des choses
comme ça si tu fais du gué me peut-être
aller si loin de plus sinon tout cas le
lot de smartphones est vraiment bien moi
j'aime beaucoup en tout cas le note 10
plus du point de vue de la photo est
facile de débloquer shiomi rémy ou en
plus ou autres ont plus de liberté de
choisir son opérateur surtout son devra
encore payer si tu es engagé si tu as un
contrat au coton opérateurs et que le
contrat n'est pas terminé tu mets pas le
faire débloquer dès lors que ton contrat
est terminé mais le débloquer tu les
appelles normalement c'est gratuit il te
le des blocs et à ce moment là tu peux
partir là où tu veux beyrouth un
smartphone qui fonctionne que tu n'est
plus engagé fait le débloquer il va
trouver un forfait quelque part pas très
cher 15 euros 10
15 euros à un forfait salut j'aimerais
changer mon samsung note 9 contre en 9
10 plus qu est ce que ça vaut le coup
non
citons note 9 marche très bien garni le
il n'y a pas beaucoup d'écart entre le
note 9 et une autre entre le one + 7 t
pro et le one plus est des pros mclaren
lequel choisir il ya un delta de 100
euros de prix 8 gigas de ram 12 il ya
drame
à mon avis si tu veut économiser 100
euros ou en plus cette épreuve bonjour
monsieur croc pour ta prochaine et à qui
j'ai une question je possède un pc deux
ans dans les nouveaux yoga 530 avec ce
genre de produits est il ya de l'intérêt
de posséder une tablette
jérémy la question c'est est ce que tu
vois toi un intérêt le posséder une
tablette est ce que ce produit te suffit
par rapport à des usages ou est ce que
tu vois un moment quelque part et te
dire neuf là il faudrait une tablette ça
aurait un sens c'est plutôt dans son sac
il faut se poser la question
un conseil pour choisir entre une
surface pro 7 ou pro x j'ai peur que la
pro x ne puisse pas tout faire tourner
et je suis content alors ok la
différence entre les produits si tu veux
la surface pro 7 et sur une évolution de
la gamme surface qui marche très bien
qu'il coule ça marche bien la surface
pro x on est sur les ordinateurs qui
sont always connected with haut doubs
toujours allumée fait pour remettre une
carte sim dans une balade et être
connecté en permanence la question elle
se pose là dessus c'est vraiment ça la
grosse différence entre ces produits si
tu l'utilisent pour tes cours et je vois
faire des jeux de temps en temps et n'a
pas besoin de collectivités en
permanence la surface procès est cool si
par contre a besoin en cours d'être
connecté à internet
à ce moment là à la surface pro x
vraiment intéressant pour moi ça que ton
avis je prends un samsung galaxy note 10
plus ou l'iphone 10 s max la question se
pose une fois de plus au niveau du style
et as tu besoin du stylet oui ou non
londres paris en avion préfère toujours
le train pour le climat alors ok j'ai
pris l'avion depuis londres où je suis
pas allé à paris sont dus à clermont
ferrand
ça m'a fait économiser beaucoup de temps
il ya un vol je crois un des rares molle
qui fait ça et c'est une vraie économie
de temps sinon pour faire londres-paris
bien évidemment je le ferai en eurostar
toi tu me dire qu'est ce que le prochain
motorola pliable sera disponible aucune
info là-dessus loïc bonjour je voudrais
savoir quelle est la marque de votre
micro cravate car je fais des
vidéothèques maison alors ok mon micro
cravate c'est un road en fait c'est ça
la rode link ce sont des petits micros
cravates qui se connecte en wifi
récepteur et sur le boîtier lui je le
branche directement tac tac tac en wifi
ça marche c'est pratique c'est pas mal
assez efficace que féroce et repos 2
howell freebox 3g pas essayer gaëtan les
web pas tant parler vous voyez mes vins
pro ou attendre le 30 pro s'il reçoit
les services google
that is the question s'ils reçoivent les
services google en tout cas le métro
sera une génération au dessus plus de
performance ça doit être cool ré mineur
c'est tout aux normes 9 arrêts minute 7
quelle est la durée de vie moyenne d'un
smartphone pour moi une durée de vie
moyenne centre 2 4 ans est-ce que tu as
entendu parler du prochain smartphone de
chez honore le view 30
pas d'infos pour le moment je suis plus
samsung mais lequel est vraiment mieux
que les autres en termes de performance
et de qualité je dirais que tout soit si
cette année quand même plutôt pas mal le
meilleur on reste dans la gamme elle
dans ce qui se fait de mieux je dirais
que le top up the top autrement c'est le
s10 plus et si tu veux utiliser le
stylet le note dispute est ce que tu as
des infos sur les prochains smartphones
de huawei qui votent représentent en
france le 7 octobre alors je devais 13
ans j'étais invité par rwe pour pouvoir
effectivement vous en parler
malheureusement je pouvais pas j'étais
en déplacement à auch on était à new
york à ce moment là mais néanmoins je ne
porte pas de huawei très prochainement
donc de symboles et des mecs n'ont comme
ça vous savez tous que penses tu du
nouveau readme qui sortent le 15 octobre
par et j'aurais dû être avec elle mais
malheureusement je n'ai pas pu être
présent j'espère le sait c'est très très
prochainement comme ça je vous dirai
tout à ton avis pourquoi asus qui est la
marque préférée a du mal à percer dans
le marché du smartphone alors qu'ils
sont très bons dans celui du laptop
c'est un peu compliqué effectivement
gendarmes ils ont des produits sont très
séduisants au niveau du smartphone et je
pense qu'ils ont un peu plus de mal à se
passionner
historiquement ils sont sur pc depuis
longtemps qu'ils sont beaucoup plus
assis sur ce domaine là le marché du
smartphone extrêmement concurrentiel
plus dur c'est pour ça qu'ils sont moins
présents là dessus que penses tu du
renmin note 8 propre on en parle la
semaine prochaine jordan c'est quoi le
tel android parfait pour les gamins de 9
10 ans moi je me pose toujours la
question à savoir est ce qu'un gamin
9-10 ans doit avoir un smartphone
toujours plus tôt ça là je me poserai
comme question quelle est l android
parfait moi je pense qu'il faut pas
chercher à mettre des gros budget pour
un enfant de 9 10 ans après elliott a
pas encore notre disant douter que quand
il aura 9 10 ans et jésus donnerait un
smartphone
je sais pas moi je pense qu'il va mettre
beaucoup de buts et un stage là bas ce
matin on a moins de 200 euros me
semblerait être pas mal comme qu'on
serrait tu entres en one + 7 t/an galaxy
s 10e ou un chiot me 1920 c'est
intéressant comme question ça moi je te
dirai owen +7 t en termes de
performances on a sabré 1955 plus je
pense que c'est là on aura une plus de
performances un écran à 14h facilement
de 90
certes ce qu'il paraîtrait que le mur du
cac mail 20 trop ou pétrole propre et
tremperont j un galaxy s cette aide
j'aimerais changer mais pas pour trop
cher max 150 euros comme conseillère
études je te conseille d'aller faire un
petit tour du côté du reconditionnés
voir que tu peux trouver ce budget là je
pense qu à de belles trouvailles à faire
peut-être sur des modèles de l'année
dernière salut tu choisirais quoi entre
la montre collecter fossiles cinquième
génération et la samsung galaxy woods
actifs de l'or j'ai testé les deux
j'aime beaucoup la fossiles pour le côté
autonomie réglable
c'est vraiment gros point positif mais
j'ai un gros coup de coeur pour la
galaxie watch active de son côté un
petit peu tactile et j'aime beaucoup
aussi
tyson qui est vraiment bien donc je
dirais la galaxie moto type 2 quel est
le meilleur photophone actuelle
comment comprendre lequel est le
meilleur si les pixels ne sont pas un
critère pour moi le vrai moyen de savoir
jauger un photophone c'est de voir le
résultat c'est toujours un peu compliqué
regarde les tests regarde les résultats
par est pas sur une fiche technique ce
qui est très très très bon cette année
c'est le pixel 4 qui marche parfaitement
bien ça me saoule avec les s10 s10 plus
marche parfaitement bien
huawei avec le pétrole pro et aussi
excellente
un trio de choc là dessus pour la photo
et l'autonomie qu'une conseillerais tu
paies 30 pro s10 plus assez intéressant
comme question moi j'étais relevait se
disputent ce que j'aime beaucoup la
colorimétrie du à 10 mais j'aime
beaucoup leur traitement d'image
le petro est excellent aussi ça se joue
à pas grand-chose pour malsaine c'est la
question du traitement d'image qui fait
la différence
quel impact à la 5g sur la santé humaine
c'est une question qui est très
intéressant que je pense qu'on va
reparler très prochainement parce qu'il
a beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
questions ça intéresse beaucoup de monde
à 5 g on en reparlera prochainement
cette question là je peux pas répondre
comme ça on juste dix secondes ça part
un peu compliqué on fera un sujet
complet
quel est le meilleur smartphone entre le
mil neuf téléphones 7 pour les réseaux
sociaux est liée ligne 1900
conseillerais quoi entre samsung est
cette aide est le one + 3 ou le elle
g6 bordel yannick écoute aph samsung est
cet âge quel budget global penses tu que
l'on devrait débourser pour avoir un bon
smartphone disposant de la 5g dès le
lancement de la 5g en 2020 on n'a pas
encore des smartphones 5 j'ai proposé en
france en tout cas donc c'est compliqué
de parler du bon budget on devrait
ouvrir sur la même gamme de prix de ce
qu'on avait en 2019
avec des smartphones 5g en 2020 c'est en
tout cas ce qui me paraîtrait que plus
intéressant mais sandra part
effectivement aussi plus tard
où as tu des téléphones avant tout je
vends aucun téléphone pour tous qu'il
aura un iphone s 2 sinon la question
c'est est ce qu'il y aura un iphone avec
un écran de 4 pouces et cakes et j'ai un
doute j'ai un doute parce qu'aujourd'hui
déjà 5,8 pouces c'est pas très très
grand par rapport à la norme donc 4
pouces je pense pas qu'apple mette des
lignes de production en route pour un
écran de 4 pouces mais j'ai un look at
you pourquoi vous ne faites pas des
vidéos de comparatifs plus approfondie
comme le font certains youtuber
américain est tout simplement parce que
s'il ya beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
fautes de tests beaucoup beaucoup
smartphones et si je veux faire des
vidéos de comparatif très approfondi sa
demande encore plus de boulot ça demande
de faire beaucoup de vidéos de
comparatifs entre un smartphone et
beaucoup d'autres donc c'est un truc qui
est un petit peu infinie et voilà c'est
un peu ça qui est compliqué pour mais
aujourd'hui ça vaut le coup s10 s10 plus
reconditionnés ou bien sûr qu'elle est
le smartphone ou le design tab le fais
moi j'ai été bluffé par je dirais en
tout cas ce qui a été fait au niveau des
smartphones pliable cd promotion de
valeurs qui sont différentes et c'est ça
qu'il vient intéressant c'est mieux le
1900 pro ou le 1909 d'éprouver
évidemment qu'est-ce qui pourrait
révolutionner le marché des smartphones
une idée pour les marques
lionel ce qui pourrait révolutionner le
marché des 'smartphones' et des usages
différents comptes d'arriva proposer
d'autres usages répondre à d'autres
problématiques et en des propositions de
valeur différente ses centres que je
trouverai vraiment très intéressant zen
fanzhi sourang fun ii où il passera la
même chose
rok flander terme de performance pure et
dure ça marche parfaitement bien salut
niveau performances et photos notes
disent plus ou iphone 11 pro iphone os
pro quand amazon publie des téléphones à
moitié prix qu en magasin ça veut dire
que c'est un fake
aide-moi sgp alors amazon c'est une
marketplace ça dépend si amazon vend
directement les produits ou s'ils sont
vendus par des vendeurs en règle
générale ça peut être des boutiques
étrangères ce qui est très important
quand on marchait sur amazon com sur
d'autres marques et de paix sans règle
générale c'est de regarder si le vendeur
regarder la note regardez les
commentaires
qui montre un peu pas de blanche il se
peut que les des tarifs beaucoup moins
cher parce qu'il est dans un autre pays
regardez ces points-là simon patte
blanche vous pouvez y aller imagine tu
pour l'évolution de huawei dans le futur
alors qu'on rende pas la question d un
petit peu compliqué parce que huawei il
n'ya pas uniquement que le smartphone
qu'on connaît et les ordinateurs et les
produits qui peuvent être soit distribué
en france on va envoyer c'est énorme il
travaille énormément au niveau de la
smart city donc c'est pour ça qu'à tous
des problématiques aussi qui sont liées
directement entre la chine et les usa
c'est la prise de contrôle au niveau de
la 5g la prise de contrôle au niveau de
la ville du futur la ville connectée je
pense que vous voyez vous alliez avoir
un acteur majeur de la ville connectée
dans la solution de connectivité globale
dans le futur au delà même de la
question du device j 1 p 20 light qui
chauffe énormément en toutou benchmark
maintenant 57 degrés sur instagram
pourrir des story est ce normal ça me
paraît quand même relativement bizarre
qu'on histoire lucas tu peux essayer de
contacter s'il est sous garantie pour
essayer de voir ce qu'il en est parce
que tout qui chauffent beaucoup pour
l'aider story paraît quand même bizarre
c'est de sauvegarder des données quelque
part et ensuite de réinstaller pour voir
que ça disent ça chauffe toujours autant
quelle est la meilleure monde connecté
de chez samsung niveau qualité prix la
galaxie aux actifs de très clairement
iphone 6 aces ou de galaxies à 50 et
alexis à 57 déplacements professionnels
hôtels + vols sont y attache à juhasz
les marques qui t'habite alors ça dépend
si c'est dans le cadre d'un lancement
comme l'a par exemple google ou
microsoft à new york ce sont eux qui
m'invitent et qui prennent tout à leur
charge
si par contre c'est moi qui vais sur un
salon et que j'ai pas de partenaires par
exemple le csa las vegas c'est moi qui
paie tout hôtel avions frais c'est moi
qui paye tout quand je suis parti
autrefois barcelone j'étais en voyage de
presse avec qualcomm ce côté l'hôtel et
l'avion quand je suis parti à l'ifa
temps voyage de presse avec samsung ceux
qui ont payé une partie de l'hôtel gp2
ce n'est pas ce que j'ai voulu rester
plus longtemps avant et après pour plus
cousin le salon et ceux qui ont payé
avion pour quelqu'un qui possède
beaucoup de playlists sur spotify par
exemple faut-il se diriger ce faire un
smartphone avec une petite capacité 32
julien 64 go de stockage et port carte
sd ou aux smartphones avec une grande
capacité 128 256 ou 512 giga mais pas de
port carte sd
la question fait elle va se poser est ce
que tu vas un compte premium
oui ou non parce que si tu es un compte
premium c'est à dire que tu stock
directement dans ton smartphone mais tu
stocks dans l'appli donc tu ne stockera
pas sur ta carte sd tout cas ce moment
là je te conseille de prendre
smartphones avec une grande capacité
si par contre tu as beaucoup de
playlists mais que tu n'as pas de
comptes premium parce qu'on va tout et
en streaming sur le serveur
donc à ce moment là la question des
capacités et tu satisfait du nombre de
membres inscrits très pointu d'organiser
des concours réservé aux membres
je réfléchis à beaucoup de choses sur la
partie manqué ce qu'on peut mettre en
place c'est en cours de réflexion
mais pourquoi pas c'est pas exclues en
tout cas sans tenir compte du prix et l'
os iphone 11 ou s10 plus à elles disent
plus est ce que tu penses que schumi va
sortir un laptop en france alors xiaomi
hippolyte a beaucoup de bruit dans son
écosystème je pense qu'ils vont être
amenées en tout cas une façon générale à
développer de plus en plus de produits à
commercer de plus de plus de produits en
europe
à terme ça me semblerait assez logique
qu'on voit arriver à l'afp l'option mis
en france j'ai l'impression que tu
adores apple j'aime beaucoup apple kevin
mais comme j'aime beaucoup aussi
beaucoup d'autres marques c'est pas de
préférence particulier j'ai pas de
partir quand tout cas pour apple que
portier du google pixels 4xl c'est
peut-être le photophone d'acheter ce
faire m en tout cas de corriger les
problèmes d'autonomie du pixel 4 salue
monsieur gros tu conseilles l'éthique
pote friùl et huawei prix buzz freebox
live
j'ai pas testé ses premiers membres et
par contre les petites peaux d'esprit
était vraiment intéressant je trouve que
tu fais beaucoup de faculty pense que tu
vas en faire moins mais avec des
questions très pertinentes
alors en fait l'idée de la faq c'est de
répondre à vos questions un peu pêle
mêle elle arrive fait de vous donner une
réponse un peu rapide pour pouvoir
effectivement répondre au maximum à vos
questions vous permet de pallier au fait
de ne pas pouvoir répondre à vos
commentaires comme ça je donne une
réponse tout le monde peut la voir ci
après vous à l'élection qui sont très
pointus pour passer un peu plus de temps
pour y répondre
j'ai une question les téléphones sortir
2019 as que leur prix baisse à partir de
janvier février 2001 en règle générale
les prix ont plus tendance à baisser
sauf chez apple car toujours une
politique de prix assez élevé voilà on a
fait le tour du côté de cette faq
j'espère que ça vous aura intéressé que
j'ai répondu à vos questions posées mois
dès maintenant toutes vos questions que
la prochaine facture en bas directement
aux commentaires de mots ce que vous
voulez toutes vos questions jeudi une
phase plus question smartphone c'est
intéressant mais je vois bien comme ça
barde aussi plein d'autres sujets parce
que je pense qu'à plein de trucs
vraiment hyper intéressant sur ce nous
embrasse tous les gros becs et je vous
dis à demain
[Musique]